welcome to this dw business special
where we're asking can china afford a
war
beijing has been carrying out military
exercises ever since a visit by u.s
house speaker nancy pelosi to taiwan
earlier this month its military vessels
now fill the seas surrounding the island
which it claims as its own as fears grow
that china could attack taiwan we're
asking if the chinese economy is strong
enough to deal with the consequences
well to discuss the various challenges
facing beijing at home we're joined by
alexander gerlach who is a senior fellow
at the carnegie council for ethics in
international affairs in new york thanks
a lot for joining us alexander there's
plenty to talk about because these are
interesting times for china watches
aren't they
thanks for having me yes and indeed they
are
when i when i lived in taiwan five years
ago there was like already like the sky
was clouding
if that's a word but now i feel we are
in the midst of a real turmoil and
tempest
well we're going to get stuck into all
of that and before we do i just want to
set out the economic situation for
people actually living in china right
now so despite decades of consistent
economic growth china remains a country
with comparatively low gdp per capita so
economic output per person when you put
it alongside the likes of the us taiwan
and germany and what's more the once
seemingly unstoppable force of china's
economy appears to be losing its
momentum the international monetary fund
expects china's econ economic growth to
steadily slow
in the coming years
so alexander gerlach has something
changed with china are the days of ever
accelerating growth and expanding middle
class over now
well i mean on a general note after
decades of growth that's not uncommon to
reach a plateau on which it then becomes
much more arduous to succeed further and
further but
that aside also china has had like quite
some bad two years in regard to the
corona pandemic and the zero corbett
policies
by the central government by xi jinping
have also uh caused a toll on the
economy as we know that global supply
chains have been
shattered if you will you have
production sites closed the city of
shanghai closed for several weeks so
that all has
not helped
the chinese economy to put it mildly
president xi jinping has built so much
of his reputation on the lives of
chinese people getting better and this
expanding middle class but now that that
economic growth is starting to slow is
that is that going to be a problem for
for xi jinping
it's it's it's more over it's a it's a
bigger problem that of course um is uh
adamant for the middle class but it's in
the bigger picture the the reason the
recent policies by xi jinping that the
common prosperity
is in his eyes a way of um
taking or like amplifying
wealth in the country and if you look
into
china and compared with the united
states you will be seeing that
inequality
is
actually almost to the exact figure like
this the same so um even though china
has a theometrical opposing political
existence in the united states they both
have embraced a certain specific form of
capitalism uh you can call it neoliberal
it's definitely not um the social market
economy that we have here in germany and
that many many western european
countries adhere to also like into a
certain extent in east asia like korea
and and taiwan do so so china has um the
jinping sorry danger pink said back in
the days let's just get a few people
rich and then it's like as we know
america trickling down to everybody but
that didn't happen so there is like a
general problem of how capitalism uh was
set up in china and now all the other
problems that happen in the real real
estate sector crisis the banking
crisis also the crisis of credits in the
framework of of
the road and belt initiatives they all
built on on the system that we see in
the united states uh already failing
like the so-called neoliberal economy so
china has to battle like and put out
lots of fires here
yeah and i'm glad you mentioned the the
real estate crisis because one of the
biggest headaches for xi jinping and
china's ruling communist party is a
crisis in the country's property sector
it goes well beyond the very well
publicized financial woes of developer
china evergrand and its 300 billion
dollar debt pile chinese property firms
have been defaulting on their debts at a
rate never seen before meanwhile angry
would-be homeowners have been boycotting
their mortgage payments they're refusing
to hand over any more money for
buildings that haven't been built yet
well alexander gerlach just help explain
how deep the crisis in china's real
estate sector really is
so in china for the longest time until
very recently it was like the investment
of the middle class if you have set
aside some money to buy apartments also
families would just gather the money and
just buy someone for the newlywed or
whatever so but the difference in china
compared for instance to germany is that
you could already pay for an apartment
that has not been built yet so it was
not in even it was maybe in the planning
status but you were already starting to
pay for it and hence also having to to
pay your mortgages that you took from
the bank to to pay this apartment so
what then happened is that the
developers would just use this money for
other
exploitations like buying more land for
more projects that have not yet been
assigned so meaning like they did not
use the money for the apartments but
then like literally when these
apartments were built they would just
take the money from the people that in
the meantime bought apartments that have
not yet been built so and it reminds a
little of the medev guy in in the
financial crisis before the financial
crisis you just also like you know took
the money of the people trusting in him
and whenever somebody asked him for
their return he would just like take the
money of someone who invested later with
him and we see this kind of um
unfolding now in china and this
unregulated market nearly now has now
just like exploded
yeah it seems like it was ultimately an
unsustainable system wasn't it but how
important is the real estate market to
china's broader economy because i
suspect it's a rather big deal
oh it has been like the the bedrock of
as i mentioned like as an it was seen as
a as a rock-solid investment form and
this is also why i mean it's always
about trust when you see crisis
financial crisis the currency crisis of
bond crisis and our real estate crisis
also just like for the longest time
people just trusted in
in
the purpose
and the revenues and the profit of
investing into apartments and that now
has been shattered so it has of course
an economic cost which other observers
are
of the same opinion
what i read like them there will be a
bailout by the government because
otherwise the middle class is going to
rate uh
you know the other
the country basically
yeah well that's the real estate sector
but let's discuss another looming crisis
facing the chinese government as well
this time relating to its vast belt and
road initiative so just five years ago
xi jinping described the sprawling
program of overseas infrastructure
investments as the project of the
century it's been
it's seen beijing fund transport routes
as you can see ports as well almost
in every corner of the globe but it
started to become an enormous burden
just recently to the chinese as borrower
countries struggle to make their debt
repayments
so alexander gerlach has china
overstretched itself with the belt and
road initiative
there has always been like a mild form
of criticism because harsh criticism
isn't allowed in china but a milestone
of criticism saying like and you
mentioned this the gdp per capita in
this country isn't great uh we don't
have schools everywhere we don't have
like good roads everywhere so why the
heck do we like invest everywhere in the
world and also especially because and
that is also not a secret and the
criteria for investing were not economic
ones but political ones so you wanted
all the belt and road initiative
projects
by chinese law need to be
used also for chinese purposes if like
people cannot pay back their loans but
then also it includes the military use
so you mean you you clearly see that the
belt and road initiative was not
designed to create
revenues and profit but to help a
political agenda and again here also the
covet 19 pandemic did not help because
that also
hindered or brought to a whole economy
economies in uh developing countries
where china has been heavily investing
and if i'm not mistaken it's 16 or 18 of
the total after almost like 900 billion
dollars that have been invested that now
are under reconstruction so it's clear
like
the boroughs cannot pay back and so
china needs to help them and the ivf he
needs to help them to to uh re um
whatsoever to recreate how to recreate
to
um rearrange the credit yeah then yes
that's right they need to restructure
their debts don't they but one of the
big
one one of the big advantages it seemed
of belton road or how it managed to to
dominate where other
foreign infrastructure plans hadn't was
that it was beijing was willing to lend
to countries that other countries
weren't willing to lend to but in the
end has has china been too careless with
who it lends to
well
the contracts that constitute all these
credits they are not public so china
doesn't make them public it's only
public if like the countries they have
to spread it given to is choosing to
somehow publish it where it's getting
leaked so all this in my opinion does
not
um
doesn't seem to me to be like the proper
way of how you do structure and build
and create these these crates especially
on that scale and globally and um so i
can only that's just an assumption i
make because there is a lack of data
here but i feel because the political
agenda was like always in the forefront
of the mind and certainly also a a
little other at least one portion of
hubris was also part of the game and
that now led to the situation china is
in now
yeah and while we're talking about
chinese foreign policy let's turn to a
situation that has developed
dramatically over the past couple of
weeks and that is taiwan so since u.s
house speaker nancy pelosi's historic
visit to the island china has responded
with a multitude of measures almost
immediately it banned imports of
thousands of taiwanese products it also
then banned exports of sand to taiwan
which the island needs for construction
and beijing created an effective
blockade of taiwan with ships patrolling
the surrounding waters
so alexander does china
really want a conflict right now
well some say so and others so like
clear is that china has emphasized the
last years more emphasized on a
non-peaceful what they call
reunification
and you always have to be clear like
china claims taiwan as a part of the
people's republic of china which just
never has been so this claim is although
it's just it's up in the air but like
that's china's interest which the united
states always said they acknowledge but
not agreed to so you have this sort of
political situation which is singular uh
in the whole world so xi jinping has
scared up his game in regard to i want
taiwan back it's his goal by latest 2049
when uh the country turns 100 and it's
also like apart it's like the the
cornerstone of this ideology the
rejuvenation of
of the nation will be completed once
taiwan is uh
in foal and belongs to the people's
republic of china within that frame
there is lots of interpretation to
whether or not she now wants an assault
on taiwan or not so we can only say that
the the assaults have gotten like more
in number by crossing the the median in
the taiwan strait by also like crossing
into taiwanese airspace so china that's
i think it's safe to say the people's
republic it's safe to say wants to
to make clear that in if they had to
they would be taking the country
by force
yeah that there's that received
political wisdom isn't there that if
things aren't going well for you as a
military as a political leader then you
you start of war or at least in this
case threaten it is that what we're
seeing here is this taiwan business a
distraction from all of those economic
challenges back home that we've been
talking about
so i i personally would
uh would say that's there's a big yes to
that she she wants to become leader for
life he wants to have a third tenor as a
president which basically then opens the
door to them uh he is not much to show
for in the 20th party congress in
october so being the commander-in-chief
and having like a vital sort of like
conflict at the doorstep and
you have to remind yourself that every
school child every kindergarten kid in
china learns that taiwan allegedly is a
part of china so he can of course like
assemble people around this this claim
and he can certainly because he also
stepped up the ultra nationalist game
during his tenure so he will he knows
even despite the fact that houses are
not
built anymore banks do not pay uh given
out money to to the people who put money
in their banks that's all in his i feel
in his uh rational the moment there is
this conflict with taiwan uh china will
unite behind him
you've already mentioned how xi jinping
has said that you know reuniting as he
would put it taiwan with the rest of
china is one of the key aims for you
know his
his leadership how likely there is an
innovation actually looking it's very
alarming when you see uh you know the
military exercises going on and the
boats surrounding
the island but
is an invasion in any way imminent
so i mean i feel like mr xi is pretty
much looking to mr putin and how what he
did in regards to ukraine and then it
was the same label kind of like we have
a military trill uh but it goes to
monday then they said no it's gonna be
until wednesday and so it's just like so
what i think the idea behind all that is
like to create like the highest degree
possible of uncertainty so that the
taiwanese army is on their toes all the
time and that this over time will wear
out the people who are like adamantly
staunchly like non-invade not in favor
of anything that's called
um reunification they also like no fans
anymore of one country uh two systems
because of what happened to hong kong so
the idea could be
to like wear them out like with military
exercises or the provocations to then
somehow heighten the pressure on another
end economically whatever to then over
time
make the taiwanese bow to this pressure
fully fully fledged invasion
at this point military strategists say
like that an amphibious assault
might be possible by equipment that uh
the so-called people's liberation army
has but maybe not by the soldiers skill
it would also be plausible or probable
that this amphibious assault would be
stopped by
submarines be taiwanese or u.s american
submarines so all in all it's like china
stepped up the game has gained more
capabilities military capabilities but
experts say like it might not lead to a
to an immediate attack on the island
okay well we can i suppose hope for that
uh alexander gerlach from the carnegie
council for ethics in international
affairs it's been fascinating to hear
what you've had to say and thank you so
much for joining us
thanks for having me
that's all for this business special
looking at the challenges facing china
and asking whether or not it can afford
a ball thanks for watching now if you've
enjoyed this there's lots more from us
on the dw news youtube channel and on
facebook and you know why not check out
our topic of the week from last week
where we discussed the true impact of
sanctions on russia it's a really
fascinating watch i'd highly recommend
it until next time do take
you